Film Courage: Jason, from an actor’s perspective
what are you looking at in terms of old footage,
what are you studying?
Jason Clarke: Everything, everything I can
get my hands on.
One of the best things I got my hands on was
this old sailing footage of Ted and Joan,
sailing the white waters of the boats that
they sailed on at this location.
Just seeing them that day on the phone in
the gear, young dudes, Ray-Bans, Joe was smoking
a cigarette, they were sailing the boat.
You’re looking for something that captures
them when they…you’re looking for both,
the public ones, the unguarded ones.
The little moments.
The mannerisms.
You know, the funeral.
There is so much on these guys, the whole
family.
I’ve watched so much on these guys.
I’ve watched a lot and read a lot on the
other brothers, not just Ted.
I didn’t just go for Ted, I went for the
others.
I went for the family.
I went for pictures of Joe, how to behave
around your father.
There is so much there.
And particularly the speeches.
There are some of the greatest speeches ever
said, ever written.
Particularly by Bobby.
Film Courage: When did you know you wanted
to be an actor?
Jason Clarke: When did I know I wanted to
be an actor?
I think when I decided I’d rather sit home
and watch movies than go to University.
“There is something in this!”
And I really wanted to be it when I couldn’t…You
realize you really want to be actor when you
can’t quite get there on auditions.
You’re not quite getting a job, you just
want it.
You can feel it.
I want to get in that door.
Film Courage: We hear about the character’s
arc.
So when you are about to go into production,
how much are you thinking of that, and what
was Ted’s arc?
Jason Clarke: A lot.
Ted’s [arc] was huge.
You’re thinking about that a lot, of course.
The best (obviously) is when you shoot in
sequence (you go from one to the other).
But you never do that.
So I’m having to make sure that if I’m
ending here, I’m starting there.
You try to give it the most that you can so
you’re not just repeating it.
So you’re really plotting it.
John [Director John Curran] and I did a lot
of work on that, going over the other scenes.
Not just rehearsing the scenes, talking over
them, rewording them, discussing them.
Ted has a massive one.
He starts off and he goes through literally
a sausage maker.
I mean he’s ground down to come out to that
final thing where 3-2-1, the pressure’s
on and you forget that that was a live event.
He got handed a bunch of really bad cards.
There’s no 15-second pause, it’s on.
Here it is, your whole career, your whole
life, your family, your moral judgment, everything…it’s
down to this.
Sitting in a room propped up on books [referring
to the press conference].
Ted’s journey of his own moral choice and
the choices that he made A) to walk away from
the car, to not stop at Dike House and knock
on the door or make a phone call at the bridge,
it’s a full on journey of how he justified
this to himself and worked it out.
Or how he decided he wanted to live or whatever
he was going to come around to.
I mean even on the phone when he goes to the
police station, he called the mother because
he does know it’s the right thing to do.
To call her up and tell her rather than somebody
else.
So there’s just so much turmoil, up and
down, before we get to the very end.
You know, and then I think that’s also reflected
in society.
How does society process this like it does
and continue to vote him in?
Film Courage: Right, he still had to keep
this public face up, which is so brilliantly
portrayed by you where he walks down the streets
and he’s ruminating about something.
Jason Clarke: Yeah…well I mean he was Ted,
he wasn’t used to this.
Is anybody ready for the fact that you’ve
gone away from a party, you’re having a
good night, it’s been a year since your
brother’s gone in front of everybody.
You’re catching up with some people that
worked passionately on this thing, you’ve
set a sailing boat, you’re relaxed coming
from Washington (D.C.) and all the sudden
bang!
You’re upside down on the bottom of a pond.
Coming out…and then where’s the girl?
And then it’s dark and cold and wet.
That’s an hour walk, that walk in the night.
It’s an hour and a half back to the house.
It gives you a lot of time to think.
Film Courage: Have we learned anything about
this incident in terms of how we view a scandal?
Jason Clarke: Have we as a society?
No…no I don’t think so, no.